[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was professional man so Cheryl
amazing content Brighton oh my goodness
you're incredible but what I love is
that he wasn't far behind okay he was
meeting you 100% the entire way I
thought the concept hey guys I'm here in
the newsroom with Madeline Moretz from
Dancing with the Stars a junior is
mental welcome to eat see live yeah
I'm not believing it man you've never
danced before the show yeah I was like
you never had dance experience until the
show call it I promise you I never have
okay so let's talk about the show
Dancing with the Stars juniors you guys
are these young adults just going out
there doing your thing your father is
Stevie Wonder growing up I mean he's a
musical legend as we all know did you
dance with him when you were younger
around the house those music I mean we
probably like pretended and like not
like serious just like joking around
like just like messing around button of
it like nothing like where I thought
like I'll be on a dance show before
nothing like that so because I always
think about when they ask people to come
on this show what their first answer is
because as you know Dancing with the
Stars juniors and their and the regular
show that's a lot of work so when I
asked you to do it what was your first
thought were you scared a little
apprehensive my first thought at first
okay so my dad told me cuz they're in
Paris because my brother was walking a
show for Dolce & Gabbana and at first my
dad called me he was like do you want to
do this dance show and I was like well
first like I'm not too sure about it but
I was like I'll try because you know be
a good experience for me and then like
when I started doing it then I was like
it started getting really fun so your
first rehearsal walking into the
rehearsal space was heart pumping nerves
of steel okay so it was crazy because
when I first walk in like I didn't know
what to expect or anything and I was
like so nervous and like my heart was
beating so fast and like I
meeting my partner Brighton and my
mentor Cheryl they were well I don't
know what they're doing they're like
doing this type of form of dance or
something into the room and I didn't
like know what they're doing and I was
like yeah this is awkward
like how did it was just fun I didn't
know what to expect them so brighton
brighton brighton brims is your is your
partner and you said in Cheryl Burke is
your mentor what has it been like
working with sure um Cheryl is hilarious
she's really funny she is she's
definitely a character she's always
helping me you know because if Brighton
I always have a problem with step in the
dance she's always helping me with it
you have for someone who is not a dancer
you have some pretty cool dance friends
Mackenzie and Maddie Ziegler her on the
show what kind of device has a Maddie
giving you well we haven't really talked
about advice on the show really remote
just like you know check like hey this
is like that's like your friend like
Maddie let's go Starbucks yeah exactly
yeah I have to touch on your fashion
because I met you earlier and in the
hospitality suite you walk up in this
amazing butterfly sweat and I told our
producer you have him give me that let's
get him a name or something but you're
into fashion your mom is a designer does
she influenced you with your with the
earth style or do you guys collaborate
she definitely you know like taught me
like cuz when I was younger I remember I
always going to like the studio with her
cuz she started off as a designer and I
guess I just got really interested into
designing from there like you know being
always in the creative mindset and stuff
like that
speaking of creative mindset what is
your favorite style of dance on the show
that you that you really like attached
to your death
identify with I have to say jive and
Foxtrot
jive and Foxtrot aren't those some of
the hardest ones to do yeah can you show
me some stuff because I I claim to be a
self-professed professional dancer but
I've never been on Dancing with the
Stars if you have a label but show me
some stuff because okay for like I said
for someone who hasn't danced before
you're smashing it man
smashing so so what you said jive and
Foxtrot yes yeah okay so let's start
with the jive
oh yeah yeah so like I remember that you
like kick really fast okay wait you kick
really bad I'm trying to come for a step
though we did okay here we go five six
we do that whatever you want you're
showing me mad I know like you go like
this and then in Foxtrot over like you
do like that's right I'm like moving I'm
like losing it I know it goes something
like that you were doing something in in
backstage oh you're doing like something
like that yeah okay hold on wait I think
that it yeah it's okay
see I teaching me how to be an amazing
dancer at man L'Amour's congratulations
your look you are a star and again I'm
not buying that you've never danced
before me no no one's buying I really
haven't
I'm serious I have it kill the bad guy
[Music]
[Applause]